un deux trois clés desserrant les engrenages de notre
famille vous réunissant pour vous présenter et vous le
gâchez c'est une mauvaise idée je veux que vous
apportiez une date au mariage de votre sœur
pensée femme Je vais trouver la bonne
fille car c'est pour Jeannie où faire  nous
allons même ce que Mike et Dave Stangl
cherchaient des dates pour
le mariage de leurs sœurs recherchaient des filles que notre
sœur aimerait nous allons avoir l'air
respectables car [ __ ] tout cela fait partie du
plan
madame
grand-mère bip Alice elle est super intelligente
Tatiana elle est  bon avenir tout le monde fous le camp
loin de moi sortez juste
pour ça
vous avez l'air bien ensemble il est si
petit il est si gros prenez tout ce qui ne soit pas
une
merde de puncheur est-ce d'accord jouons à la pétanque nous
le prenons facilement
absolument maintenant  vous les gars [ __ ] attendez oh
vous trébuchez je ne peux pas continuer à porter
ça marche qu'avez-vous proposé de lâcher
les âmes se réunissent là pour me tenir
toi